sunday's big show the grammy awards on
cbsn
guess who is already red carpet ready ah
the one and only kelty knight who just
talked to a three-time nominee
that's right kev hi from grammy
rehearsals and i got to talk to miranda
lambert today and she told me all about
her plans
for her grammy glam keep the blue bird
in my heart
a dress and a really hot husband who has
a really nice suit so we're we're good
on that so where you going princess are
you going sleek and sexy
sleek and sexy not really princess gal
miranda's promising plenty of glam even
if she and hubby brendan mclaughlin
are walking a socially distant red
carpet on sunday
her grammy noms include best country
song for bluebird which she'll be
performing
live with her band
[Music]
can you sneak us a little bit of info to
look forward to on sunday
well the set is beautiful it's very
feminine and beautiful and uh also
there's an energy with my band and i
because we haven't played bluebird
really since it's been bluebird
we released a new song is already number
one on billboard with al king was so fun
i love elle king i'm a huge fan of hers
and uh we we toured together on my tour
roadside arts pink guitars it's all
girls
and we just became friends and she
called me and asked me to sing on this
song and send it to me and i'm like
duh this wild card's also making history
as the first female country star to open
a restaurant
on broadway in nashville this summer
tell me about casa rosa
my favorite things are the pink tufted
booths okay
and the giant rhinestone saddle
it's a disco ball saddle and it's
humongous and it makes me
just smile from here